it is a city use to water but it's hard
for residents to cope with the reality
like this menaces famous at marks square
now enveloped by a carpet of water
tourists though enjoyed the novelty of
what has been a record high tide this
week capturing scenes which for them
will be a holiday memory but speak have
lost trade and damage to businesses in
the city only today we stain that's why
because the water is let's finally we
find and we appreciate more out food now
all the restaurants were closed and also
the shops were closed so our day
spending was finding food yesterday so
yeah this was the defense system which
should have kept the water at bay
protecting Venice its people and its
precious history but it is still a work
in progress after years and billions of
pounds in the making and the city's
mayor warned the cleanup will be costly
he met with Italy's Prime Minister
Giuseppe Conte in Palestrina one of the
many islands that dot the Venetian
Lagoon where two people died this week
Conte remarked that Venice was on its
knees I saw a lot of distress great
distress today I spoke to a newsstand
owner who saw his entire kiosk collapsed
into the gia Decca Canal he lost
everything can you imagine what it means
for someone who owns a business to see
his entire world drowning in the water
but he knows that even as the work goes
on to deal with the damage and threat to
life already inflicted on Venice more
flood water is set to engulf the city
this weekend the Dwain as predicted it
does there will be growing anger here
about a city still waiting for the
protection long-promised Michele
Clifford sky news